did you ever try and uh do anything
sneaky with your suitcase at the airport
you would try to like get past the
weight limit how so
uh
one time i remember which airport it was
in
the the thing where the suitcase was
yeah there was no other staff to this
side yeah i was just the person there
behind the desk yeah and uh i had i had
the suitcase just like the suitcase i
had was kind of like uh the wheels were
kind of
like not centered not on the edge but
like kind of sent going towards the
center so the edge was leaning off yeah
and so i just do that thing where you
just like put your foot and just like
slightly lift it up so like get a
kilogram or two off and then just hold
it like like like some kind of men user
yeah yeah you gotta have the
conversation while just slightly holding
it because it was gonna go over yeah i
knew it was over because on the way
there it was over yeah on the way back
how much was it over like five kilograms
okay so i'm not getting away with that
so i no i did huh i got it down to like
it was just 20 kg limit right yeah it
was going to like
24kg who are you flying with
most of the airlines have 20 kg on one
bag limit it's not 23. normally 20
actually depends on the airline
a lot of them yeah sometimes yeah
sometimes 15 is up okay so i i was like
i need to show five off this bad boy
right now and it was so calm dude it was
so hard because i'm like i'm like on the
desk like this trying to get my
documents and i'm like
my foot is like steel right yeah like
lifting it up but you got to keep it
even because if it's wobbling they know
what you're doing yeah yeah but like
what i figured like what are they gonna
do they're gonna kick me off the plane
if they find out i'm doing it it doesn't
rise here like you know in georgia where
they put the chocolate under the water
while you're just having a conversation
it's like i've been [ __ ] with you
this entire time i knew
because i had to pay the fee on the way
there yeah i didn't have any other way
of taking it they charged me like
seventy dollars or something yeah
the flight was like 300. yeah i was
broke yeah i couldn't afford 70. so i
was like i'm gonna do this bro so yeah
it was like a jojo like fight thing i
was like holding it up with my like left
foot on the desk doing my passport
getting the ticket he was like
put it on and when i put it on i just
kept talking to her yeah it seemed like
nothing was i wasn't that close to her
either but like she because the desk was
really tall yeah and there was no one
else so you can't see me doing it
there's no one behind me and i was
scared that someone would call me out
but yeah one did so yeah it will work
nicely so if there was someone behind
you that would just be like damn yeah
yeah if somebody called me yeah i'd have
been like what is wrong with you yeah
let me you are you wanna be [ __ ] over
by them too come on but one time i will
say uh when i was moving to japan and i
had like three suitcases the woman was
like my suitcases were like way over
yeah because i had like my computer gear
yeah so it was like it was like 10 15 kg
over yeah and she just like looked at me
and i was like i must look really sad
because i was like i was like i'm moving
and she's like
all right i won't tell anyone and then
she just let it off
sometimes i love when they do yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because because like it's
so hard so because like here's the thing
like i i've had to like do similar
things but i tried to prepare as much as
possible before going in so you you
weigh it and you're just like how much
how much can you like physically bring
on a carry-on okay
you push that to the limit because you
have you have the carry-on and then
sometimes you can have like a bag which
is not too big or it doesn't allow that
to be too big you know you know but like
you you push the limits about how much
you can have on a carry-on and a
personal personal item is that's what
it's called right personal personal item
yeah right so you you have to spread
things as equally as possible and i
noticed like the magic number is between
like point five and one kilograms right
if it's between if it's over by like
less than like one kilogram or just like
like i've met airlines that it's like if
it's exactly one kilogram they will
charge you but if it's like
0.9 they're just like
we'll let it go well then again
the 0.1 kilograms makes a big difference
that just reminded me of like the time
when i got stranded in canada right one
time because i lost my passport right so
i don't know if i told this story on
trash days but like like years like this
is like five six years ago i went i went
to uh i went to a con in montreal
and uh and you know i was like hanging
out with a bunch of mates and whatever
and then i was flying back to australia
but i had to stop by in toronto first so
it was like montreal to toronto and then
toronto back to sydney right so then i
got to montreal airport
and i was like i can't find my [ __ ]
passport
and you know this is the first time ever
i've lost my passport let alone overseas
right yeah yeah which is [ __ ]
terrifying i find out later that my
friend who was with me at the con the
entire time i'd accidentally put my
passport in his bag and he had already
flown home back to like i think he lives
in like san jose or something right so
he was already in america with my
passport in his back
and so
i got to montreal airport that's like
nightmare it was it was a [ __ ]
nightmare i think i'd cry yeah
like and like i got to montreal airport
i told them the situation they were like
all right what you can do is that
there's an australian embassy in toronto
anyway yeah so just we'll let you fly to
toronto at least but then we're gonna
have to but then you're gonna have to
find a hotel go to the embassy get a new
passport right right so you know i'm
[ __ ] freaking out right so i fly to
toronto get put in a hotel
and then my friend who had the passport
was like i can try and like
email like not email email
i can try i can try this like send this
to you like mail it to you right through
like fedex or whatever but like i don't
know how long it's gonna take right not
to mention it's technically in a
different country yeah so it has to go
through like customs and [ __ ] yeah right
i stayed in that hotel for five days
straight god every day i'm fedex took
five days five days bruh bro does he
just like cheap out no no no no no no no
it was stuck in customs for like three
and a half days so it got to canada like
on the morning of day two but because
it's just a passport yeah it was
literally just stuck in customs for like
three whole days what the [ __ ] were they
doing i don't know checking it was
legitimate or something like no illegal
activities or whatever but like i do
like i was so [ __ ] depressed because
like i'm stuck in this area in this
hotel in the middle of toronto i don't
know anyone who lives there right yeah i
wake up in the morning and i'm literally
sitting in front of the reception phone
just hoping that i get a call being like
you've got a package
right i hope you had an ergonomic
keyboard no i did it
i was
so like so the first thing i had to do
though was i had to go to toronto
airport to like change my flight right
to be like hey i've lost my passport i
don't know what to do and it was like
this like canadian woman who was there
and she was like okay um you know
because it's an unfortunate situation we
can change your flight for free
if you fly tomorrow
right and you know i didn't know when
this package was gonna arrive right so i
was just like okay yeah sure let's do
that yeah you know just so i don't get
my fight completely cancelled yeah of
course next day happens
it doesn't arrive yeah so then the next
day i had to go back to toronto airport
and the same woman was there right and
she was like okay
if you want to change it to like two or
three days later which is the next
available flight it's gonna cost you
like
you know a couple of thousand dollars
yeah right and at the time you know
because i'd only just started doing
youtube i didn't have that kind of money
you know i was still living off [ __ ]
scraps
for youtube
and so i was like and you know i i was
like on the verge of tears being honest
i was like on the verge i'd be crying
already like i was on the verge of tears
and just being like
i i was just like i don't have that kind
of money right now and i was like what
do i do should i call my mom but it's
like three in the morning in australia
right now yeah
and then the woman just like kind of
like was just looking at me panicking
for a little bit and then she just
starts typing away on a keyboard
and then she prints out this ticket
for two days to go and she hands it to
me and then she just i'll never forget
it she just says i better not see you
here ever again
and she just gave me this dude i [ __ ]
cry
i got on my knees and i just broke down
crying because this lady just literally
just gave me this 2 000 yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah just because she felt sorry
for me yeah and i'm like that would
never happen in japan
in japan it's like hold on i'm going to
call up the manager and then the
manager's manager no no no no no no no
no no no no they'd be like they would
never let it happen so like luckily two
days later i got the [ __ ] you know
passport and i got the package and i
[ __ ] ripped that [ __ ] open to the
hotel room saw my passport broke down
crying again because i'm like finally i
can go home
and then yeah i got to toronto airport
and i got my flight back and i was like
whoever you were a lady i will never
[ __ ] forget you that was like that
was the moment where i was like you know
what
people are awesome there is there is a
god